Marissa Jaret Winokur teases a possible
hairspray live appearance come on cameo
a little something will
et chatted with Marisa at the Kubo and
two strings premiere in la Sunday where
she said she's itching to be a part of
the upcoming television musical I'm
Laketown for anything I've even told
them I'm like I'm down for I'm done for
like a wink-wink like in the window like
I just want to be a part of it and have
fun and like and I'm excited and I'm so
excited
yesterday I was literally doing the tram
ride at Universal Studios and they're
like that's what they're doing hairspray
I'm like that's the stage like I'm like
the loser in the tram being like
hairspray live is headed to NBC in
December with stars like ariana grande
Jennifer Hudson and Derek Hough taking
center stage y'all better look the Tony
winner also shared she's already met
actress Maddie Bailey oh the newcomer
said to play Tracy Turnblad the role
Marissa made famous on Broadway
she's just amazing and wonderful and
young and sweet and perfect and I'm so
excited for her I can't wait my advice
to her was I said be yourself whatever
don't try to be me don't try to be Ricki
Lake like just be yourself and whatever
they hired you why they hired you and
just do you be the best you you can be